I've been working till the break of 4 45
I get an automatic raise and I can't be
fine must wait till Edge 57 till I can
retire with an inflation-adjusted
pension that continuously keeps going
higher oh it's a damn shame what the
world's come to they want us back in the
office on Mondays too wish I could just
wake up and it not be true but it is oh
it is not living in the real world
is a lot harder than you'd know sure I
got Dental but it's bad I go mental
cause I had to fill out both of these
forms I asked
all surprise hacks on Necessities I had
to purchase my rental in Ocean City
please don't tell anyone it's so
embarrassing the plight of rich man
north of Richmond
hey we have to have cameras on for
today's meeting
thank you
I just sit here wasting my whole life
away cause this verification code is
taken all day how do you expect me to
check my 401k plus my fudge round
supplier no longer takes Apple pay oh
it's a damn shame what the world's come
to it takes one person to do my job so
we have to wish I could just wake up and
it not be true but it is
oh it is not living in the real world
is a lot harder than you know sure I got
health care but I get an in-depth scare
only weeks left to open enroll new God
blessed with this pen he just sits there
and snaps how am I again
on my 2PM naps they want us back now on
Tuesdays I just might collapse The
Plight a rich man north of Richmond
[Music]
we're just like you
okay
[Music]